there's a lot going on for you right now
is in there yeah it's been kind of crazy
Universal that's a word though it's in
your vocabulary now you signed how's
that it's been amazing this past year
that we've been signed with them all
they've been doing and all I've wanted
to do actually is just be in the studio
make music write songs and it's been
lots of fun now you've been doing that
for a while that feeling of being in the
studio making your own music is that as
such an adrenaline for you to be doing
it hold on you know I'm 15 now it's like
I can't even explain it it's kind of
weird it's like I feel like I'm just
like like meant to be there I'm just
like I feel so calm when I'm in the
studio it's like I'm that's where I feel
most comfortable
what music or artists inspire you I
would say for sure Justin Bieber Shawn
Mendes but I do also listen to a lot of
like hip-hop rap I like low baby he's
kind of sick yeah I like gypsy alright
gonna yeah have you met with the Shawn
Mendes I oh yeah I did meet him actually
I met him on an airplane funny enough I
need a leader magnet and an event going
to LA from Toronto
he was like sitting in the seat behind
me I was tremendous did you talk to him
do you talk I need some advice sir yeah
he was really tired though the guy was
like nice to meet you man yeah so I kind
of felt bad oh yeah he was really great
now you have a song last summer a huge
hit for you thank you the reaction to
that song it's been a lot of girls kind
of reacting to it wasn't it well what
does your mom think about the whole
situation um my mom can we just stay out
of that part no she's not here not here
with us right now that I think she's
like watching people soundcheck she's
like this is so cool
oh yeah she kind of like doesn't like to
really intervene in that part of thing
in that kind of things but yeah it's
been most of most of you people are
saying is that my sound is getting a lot
older which I agree with I'm getting a
little bit I'm a little man now
but that song is about a girl isn't it
hmm which girl not any girl and specific
to be honest it's just it's more about
being with friends and being with family
and having a great time meeting a couple
people along the way and just having a
great summer now there was a lot of
female fans yes and I always like to ask
the question would you ever date someone
who's a fan who was female yeah
absolutely you would
that's a fan you wouldn't you wouldn't
mind yeah I feel like if you're gonna
have a girlfriend they should be
supportive of you anyway even if even if
they weren't a fan before if you have
somebody in your life that doesn't agree
with what you do or doesn't support you
then like are they really there for you
are you working on you music right now I
I am yeah I'm putting out an EP in the
new year and then it's really go along
with that so Christmas is around the
corner
yep any plans this Christmas any rituals
that you do with your family oh we used
to we used to always just sit around the
tree open presents from oldest to
youngest I believe and we actually can't
do that this year because we're in LA so
hopefully we'll be able to open presents
with all the wrapping and stuff like
that but we won't have a tree China
sucks it's all good though we're gonna
be doing music stops yes that's cool
anything you want for Christmas
whoo
new docks you dock
yeah it was a pretty good job hey there
you go let you kids know it's new
dollars for Christmas there's a lot of
people gonna be sending you Docs now
please do
you